[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur mon iphone 4
avec 24 j'espère que vous passez une
bonne journée nouvelle école dernière
née des radios associatives la maison de
l'action radiophonique et de la mobilité
des idées sur trappe et ses environs
comprenez la marmite s'est installé cet
été sur le 88.4 une nouvelle radio
associative qui place la barre très haut
en proposant des programmes citoyens
éducatifs culturels mais aussi
expérimentaux à l'image des jingle de la
station pour le moins inédit sur la
bande fm vous avez écouté ma vous
écouterai à l'antenne ce sont les
bénévoles qui s'exprime et plus
particulièrement les habitants de
trappes toutes les émissions sont
réalisées par des amateurs
mais pas question pour ces responsables
d'en faire une radio de seconde zone
je voulais une antenne professionnelle
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on est
associative qu'on peut se permettre de
faire tout et n'importe quoi et c'est
vrai que moi j'avais envie d'une antenne
professionnel c'est pour ça qu'on se
donne le droit de refaire et de refaire
des émissions de faire un pilote de
refaire une émission juste jusqu'à tant
qu'elles soient professionnelles à mon
goût des émissions qui recherchent une
qualité professionnelle ouverte sur la
musique les communautés ou encore les
écoles qui viennent compléter une grille
musical tout aussi diversifiée on essaye
de toucher un maximum de la population
ou trappe
donc on essaie mais carrément tous les
genres de musique
on a eu des retours il ya des personnes
qui disent que
bien justement puisque il ya un mélange
de plein de genres de musique et les
gens qui n'écoutent pas forcément de la
chanson française il
il écoute quelques morceaux ils disent
ah tiens celui-là lé bien donc qui
commence à apprécier
donc on essaye de bien faire ça puisque
trouvait jean trappe
après si bien cette radio l'antenne de
marmites fm n'a pas fini de se
développer une émission sur les droits
des citoyens est en cours de préparation
mais pour recevoir chaque jour de
nouvelles propositions il faut avant
tout faire connaître la radio entre en
contact c'est presque individuellement
aller leur parler leur faire comprendre
que la radio c'est pour tout le monde
que aussi peuvent la faire en faisant
faire parce que
parce que c'est pas évident il pense que
c'est pas à leur portée et leur
expliquer qu'il faut simplement parler
de ce dont on a envie de parler leur
quotidien ou de choses qui les passionne
je vous soyez trappistes ou non et si
vous avez des projets d'émissions
contacter directement la radio pour les
grands timides qui préfèrent rester
derrière leur poste marmite fm et mais
sur un rayon de près de 30 km les lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi de 13h à 18h et
le mercredi de 13h à 21h le week end les
ondes sont en ébullition à partir de 9h
jusqu'à 13 heures allez bonne journée
écouter marc métais même 90 points 4
[Musique]
l'obtention d'une étoile au guide
michelin est un événement pour un
restaurant lorsqu'il y en a deux d'un
coup comme gordon ramsay au trianon
palace à versailles et qui plus est un
an après l'ouverture
on peut imaginer la joie du chef et de
son équipe simonet d'anonymes et le chef
des cuisines chargée de veiller au
respect de la qualité
gordon ramsay nom du chef cuisinier
écossais auprès duquel il travaille
depuis 12 ans soixante-dix personnes
composent la brigade en charge du
restaurant gastronomique et obtenu deux
étoiles mais également de la brasserie
en outre en chef c'est qu'on peut
remonter un acteur à avoir une heure ce
cas et ses larmes en là la plus belle
récompense pour tout le travail qui nous
a mis dedans france et une cousine coup
mais je suis beau parcours est rappelé
sa cousine grands classiques classique
c'est parce que tu le tourneur la
recherche de nouveaux ingrédients des
nouvelles combinaisons des dépouilles
deux étoiles pour un restaurant sont
autant de gages de qualité mais
également de retombées financières après
avoir été rénové dans un style plus
contemporain le gordon ramsay se veut
plus familial une grande majorité de la
clientèle est extérieur à l'hôtel et 50
couverts sont servis chaque soir la
clientèle est française
à un haut niveau est beaucoup plus basse
monique labrune connaissance et maman
plus être les élèves et des produits
le prix moyen d'un repas au restaurant
gastronomique est de 220 euros si le
prix reste élevé pour le client lambda
n'oublions pas qu'ici il s'agit de luxe
du très haut de gamme et chaque étoile
représente un enjeu qui en appelle un
autre
si on négocie à d'avoir la deuxième il
faut que mon continent français qui un
jour ont fait arrivé à la troisième
et là je pense que ça va assez bas télé
le prochain challenge
[Musique]